[Musique]
implanté depuis sa création attrape le
site de volvo construction équipement
france est spécialisé dans les engins de
travaux publics maintenance et venté ne
pour en parler nous sommes avec le
président de volvo c e délit guimard
bonjour bonjour alors est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer concrètement
qu'est ce qui se passe à trappes eh bien
on est sûr trappe
le siège de la marque et de la filiale
volvo construction équipement donc
marque suédoise et on dirige l'ensemble
des opérations en france la partie seule
en service et donc on pilote tout un
réseau de concessionnaires et on
représente en gros 7 800 personnes sur
le sur les réseaux france et en plus on
a quelques activités supports notamment
entrepôts pièces de rechange et une
grosse succursales qui gère l'ensemble
du secteur grands pas ici il y as encore
à 140 collaborateurs c'est bien savoir
effectivement avec une partie atelier
donc qu'est-ce que c'est en fait qu'est
ce que c'est les engins de travaux
publics
alors c'est vrai que volvo on a
l'habitude de
voir la voiture le groupe volvo à un
certain nombre de business area
différentes donc le camion qu'on connaît
un peu plus classiquement et la partie
tp donc sur la partie tp on a les
machines qui sont ce qu'on appelle des
machines de production donc tout ce que
vous allez retrouver en carrière donc
pour venir faire des trous transporter
les cailloux des agrégats etc
et puis après plus classiquement aussi
des machines un peu plus petit que vous
avez retrouvé sur sur la partie urbain
des mini-pelles mini chargeuses pour
faire les travaux de voirie ou alors
après demain si vous voulez creusez vous
même votre propre piscine vous avez la
possibilité de aussi avoir des machines
volvo actuellement vous êtes en phase de
recrutement
alors on il ya une crise sanitaire et
une crise économique et pourtant vous
recrutez et effectivement l'année pour
nous 2020 a été on va dire en trois
phases
ça fait suite à trois quatre années où
les marchés bâtiment travaux publics
était plutôt sur des belles tendance
2016 2019
on a commencé la première phase 2020
comme on avait fini 2010 neuf donc sur
une très très belle dynamique
naturellement on a subi de plein fouet
le confinement le premier qui était
naturellement pas prévu sur lequel il a
fallu qu'on gère comme tout le monde
donc on s'est complètement arrêté et
puis en fait depuis le mois de juin on
est sur une tendance où les activités
sont en train de reprendre alors avec
des grands enjeux autour des des
chantiers dans les régions mais on a la
chance d'avoir notamment sur le grand
paris un gros gros projet grand paris
express et donc on a retrouvé une
cadence quasiment quasiment similaire à
l'avant crise on a fait une fin d'année
plutôt plutôt très correct donc on a
repris notre notre démarche de
recrutement et notamment sur la partie
mécaniciens mécaniciens pour le mans et
justement on va les rencontrer un de vos
collaborateurs mécanicien référent
technique sur le site de trappes pour
découvrir en quoi consiste l'activité de
mécanicien sur les engins de travaux
publics
[Musique]
et nous avons rejoint christophe
garnotel bonjour bonjour vous êtes
référent technique sur le site de
trappes de volvo construction équipement
[Musique]
alors en quoi consiste le métier de
mécanicien sur les engins de travaux de
public
comme nous avons derrière nous la alors
contrairement aux idées reçues c'est
vrai que on pense toujours technicien
faire des vidanges changer des ampoules
je pense que maintenant c'est révolu
même si c'est toujours d'actualité de
faire des vidanges
c'est quand même beaucoup plus poussée
on part maintenant sur delà du
diagnostic en électronique en
pneumatiques hydraulique la motorisation
thermique et bientôt maintenant de la
machine 100 % électrique quelqu'un un
mécanicien traditionnelle qui s'occupait
de voitures peut intervenir sur ce type
de danger alors en suivant des
formations en ayant des bases techniques
en automobile il peut très bien basculer
sur des travaux publics
bien sûr on souvent des formations un
peu plus poussées sur sur la gamme de
produits quel est le parcours
traditionnel chez volvo construction
équipement
alors si je prends mon exemple par
exemple je suis j'ai fait un bep en deux
ans en alternance chez volvo
j'ai enquillé sur un bac pro en deux ans
j'ai eu l'opportunité d'être embauché au
sein d'ateliers pendant 3 ans en tant
que mécanicien de maintenance mais
atelier puis passé en tant que
dépanneurs pendant sept ans sur la route
donc là me déplacer chez les clients et
dépanner machine sur site et depuis
bientôt deux ans maintenant j'ai intégré
les bureaux à trappes et je suis sûr
référent technique donc je suis en
support pour les techniciens ateliers et
sur la route
l'activité je suppose qu'elle ne cesse
d'évoluer exactement ça n'arrête pas ça
n'arrête pas toujours toujours une
remise en question parce que les
produits évolue la gamme évolue les
technologies évoluent donc toujours sur
sur le qui vive pour pour être
opérationnels et c'est pour ça que vous
êtes en phase de recrutement en ce
moment exactement
merci christophe garnotel pour nous
avoir fait découvrir ce métier de
mécanicien
justement si vous êtes intéressé par ce
poste ce type d'activité n'hésitez pas à
vous rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran